i can tell you this they have all the
evidence
they need to show the fans what did and
did not happen
it is salacious it is unbelievable
it is grimy and
it is shocking
if you don't like my shade then step out
of my
shadow kenya more
season 13 of the real housewives of
atlanta it's a very different season for
a number of reasons but how are you
feeling about it
you know what i think it's an exciting
season i think we
though it was challenging but i think we
we did our thing i mean we have this
platform
you have the number one show on bravo
with an all black female cast
it's important that we are allowed to
tell our real stories
and what is actually affecting us in the
world this is a is a
is a perfect opportunity to be able to
tell our truth
without being ashamed or without
um judgment and i think that it's time
let's get into the personal story you're
bringing to the table this year
we meet you in what feels like a pretty
low moment
as you know i've only been married three
years we have been separated for over 10
months
it's not something i initially wanted
this is not my first time speaking with
a divorce attorney this is just the
first time
that i have decided to figure out what
my options are before i take action
and file what's it going to be like to
have to relive everything you've been
through with mark and everyone learning
what you've been through with mark
uh it's not going to be easy for me it's
never easy for me
um when you are vulnerable and you put
yourself
out there but i'm not only putting
myself out there and putting my husband
my daughter my family because all of
those
emotions and instances are sort of
intertwined so it's it's difficult
because
they often don't know what i've said um
or they don't often know
how i really feel and i think that
having this platform allows me to
sort of um get therapy
in a way because i'm talking through
things that i may not necessarily want
to talk about or don't talk about
you and mark were just together for
brooklyn's second birthday
it looks like a happy family photo
what's can you share any update on the
state of your marriage where things are
right now
i wish i could tell you um
you know we're still separated and um
i have gone through the gamut of
emotions
from being happy and happy to move on
to being kind of sad and looking at
brooklyn
and seeing the love and knowing what an
amazing family we had
and could we still have it so for me
um it's the best way to describe it is
that i feel
turmoil a lot through the season because
i'm being pulled in different directions
and
and just until recently um
things really shifted so as you saw from
the birthday party
shifted in a good way shifted in a
different way
yeah you know i say shift it in a
different way because i don't know where
where my heart really is right now and
for me that's not like me
i have to look inside myself to say
do i owe this person another chance so
we'll see there is in the premiere a
it's a real moment it feels like between
cynthia candy and you where they're
basically saying
you've tried all you can do let it go if
mark makes you happy i'm you're poor
but if he's not making you happy right
but couples go through up and downs and
i was okay
riding that wave with him because you
know i got married for better
or for worse so does he make you happy
when that question was asked absolutely
no
no in that moment no because i didn't
feel like he was fighting for
me and um i had been resolved to just
say you know what i'm not going to
make myself miserable if someone doesn't
want me
because i am the prize and if they don't
recognize that then it's just time for
me to move on
and maybe on to something new different
or even better
last year we met ken
so mark calls kenya can i love it when
she's kid
cause ken she has the [ __ ] does ken
still exist
or how we have we let ken move on out
so what's interesting is i
am in a very different place in my life
i will not bow down to a man i will not
beg for love and attention and those
things kind of come from as i've learned
through the season and we reveal
things that happened to me when i was a
child in my childhood and what i needed
and what i didn't get and how that
manifests itself
in my relationship and so it's a really
interesting journey
if you follow along i think that um
there will be
some moments where it's like oh it's
very cathartic
um and very telling
what you just said then and then from
what's in the premiere i'm focusing on
what makes kenya happy it sounds like
that's
maybe the journey you really focused on
during this very crazy time
in the world yes yes it became
real because now
i'm at home all of the time by myself
and i went through a lot of
health issues i went through a lot of
emotional issues as i'm sure
a lot of us have so i think that
people will identify hopefully they will
in my story in
my journey because i wanted to refocus
the negative energy and turn it into
something positive especially for
the um the livelihood and for
the happiness of my daughter yeah i
i told you last year when you came back
to the show motherhood had
totally changed how you operated in the
world and
that's you continue to be on that
evolution path and
i've noticed you being more and more
open i mean you
in september you shared your exact
weight on instagram can you that is not
something people do
why did you decide to be open with that
because it's you know we all
we've all put on the cove in 19 we've
all dealt with that
no not just 19. for me
it's it's i'm bucking around 30 30 extra
pounds
so listen we all have been through it
i literally am 30 pounds heavier than
after i
three weeks after i had my child
that is a lot of ways
so um i think sharing can help people
that's just what i think it's nothing to
be ashamed of
because you can lose it you know and
by sharing it just it just helps people
that might be in the same situation as
you
i think you look amazing big birthday
coming up in january and a year ago you
were not looking forward to that number
okay you're
what you're doing right now makes it
seem like you're still not looking
forward to it
what is it about that number that makes
you um
hold your hand to your head you know
what i
i have to say where i am spiritually
emotionally i am
loving turning that number next year
i feel like i can conquer the world
there is
nothing that i cannot do and
if that means turning 50 that's what it
means then please can i turn 50 tomorrow
but at the same time i'm in hollywood
i'm a black actress
um and there is a lot of ageism that
exists
so there isn't a cap placed on
what i can what i can do but once you
confirm that
then i think that it's a possibility
that hollywood might go oh you know that
you know she can't play the hot girl
anymore she can't play this part anymore
so
that would be my only real concern
i don't think one you should worry at
all all right
gotta take a sharp pivot here to this
year's gate there's always a hyphen gate
on real houses of atlanta this year it's
stripper gate
yes
i'm hearing sex noises coming from a
bedroom
it wasn't a sex party
who said that she's making disparaging
comments
about me and you involving a script wow
i'm overdosed
will fans get answers about what did or
did not happen at cynthia's bachelorette
party
well i can tell you this they have all
the evidence
they need to show the fans what did and
did not happen
um whether they show that
in the edit is something different which
i have no control over
i do know that it is salacious it
is unbelievable it is
grimy and
it is shocking cynthia
told me that your arms might be a little
tired from um some pot stirring you
maybe did in this uh
scenario what do you have to say to that
this is what i
don't like about my position on the show
so if i'm an honest voice and i call
people out then somehow i'm a villain
but if it were me and i got caught
stripping the the stripper
you know that came to the bachelor party
i would have been dragged from
from here to california you know what i
mean so
i don't think that it's fair that people
will call that pot stirring
we are a cat and we are in a cast
house and if something happens like that
in a cast
house while you are working then it
should be
discussed you can't do that at
mcdonald's you can't go in
the bathroom at mcdonald's and have sex
with someone and think it's okay
because hey you know you were in a
closet
no you were at work i am
dying at that that reference but that
that helps to paint a picture for me
did you that the trailer makes it seem
like you
heard something so did you kind of
witness
oh i've heard i've heard a lot and other
people heard a lot
very specific things very specific
things and very specific voices okay
i mean there's been a lot of not the
only one okay
let's talk about some of the really
great this year
fans kind of freaked out when you and
marlo posted a selfie what can you tell
me about
coming together joining forces with
marlowe hampton
you know um i think it kind of
goes back to me being a changed person i
think
that i am always and have always been
a very forgiving person but you have to
work to get that forgiveness meaning
apologize and then change the behavior
all that's all i've ever really asked of
someone who is sincere
and we had a moment where
we had a very sincere and honest
conversation
after obviously dueling it out all
season
and you know i have to say it's it's
very
it's one of the highlights of the entire
season
i can imagine now you know the fans want
you to have that same kind of moment
with
porsha from what's kind of trickled out
there doesn't sound like that's gonna
happen what is it about you and portia
that
things just don't align for you to have
a friendship like that you would have to
ask her that question because for three
years
i considered her a friend i was very
supportive i remember going to her baby
shower reaching out to her
even when she had her spin-off i was
tweeting about it
i was you know sharing her joy with her
and i actually had love for her so for
her to turn on me when nene came back i
think the fans and every
everyone saw that so that's a question
for her
because my heart has always been open
and i've always
been consistent from the time
from three years ago when i showed up at
her play
and i would support her no matter what
those things that she's doing to me
especially this season
is just it's just really disgusting
okay not great for you but it makes me
and intrigued to watch and excited to
watch
and we've we've gotten everyone on on
the show but
when people don't want to be friends
with you because they feel threatened or
they feel
um a certain way that they don't want
you to be bigger than them
i think that is really what comes into
play and that's a page out of nene's
book
honestly and she's been taking a lot of
pages out of newton's book lately
and not in a good way showing up three
hours
late to the set the demanding of certain
things happen
um uh footage being
um taken out because she doesn't like
the way that she looks
you know that's kind of neemy behavior
so unfortunately
yeah we have a little nene junior on our
set
okay we got a couple newbies this year
too drew sedora with a peach
i bring the flavor to atlanta don't
worry i'm from chicago [ __ ]
and latoya ali you can do what you want
while you're separated
what who says that you're still married
what vows did you take what do we need
to know about these kids
latoya is amazing she's refreshing she's
a little spitfire
she's sexy she's just energetic
she has a unique energy and i absolutely
adore what she brings to the show we
also had another
um friend of the show fallon who is
absolutely stunning fabulous
a wife very wealthy her husband adores
her
i really hope to see more of her if not
this season next season for sure she
should be holding a peach
okay you did not say anything about drew
there which implies maybe you don't want
to talk about drill
you're a clever fan aren't you
okay i'll i i'll ask you one question
about drew if you had to compare her to
another housewife we've met in a
in on atlanta in another city is she
like anybody
no i think that she reminds me of
um a kim
fields um i loved kim fields even though
i didn't treat her
like i loved her everything about you is
tired oh wonderful let's go and get the
divorce and then i'll keep the friends
because nobody really seems to like i
like oh everyone loves me honey guess
what they say about you behind your back
snooze fest
okay it's really okay let me pull your
i loved her as the icon that she is but
on the show
being the actress i believe
that it just wasn't genuine like she
wasn't telling her authentic
uh story and i feel that
that might be who i pair her with
because i kind of get the same vibe from
drew okay cynthia said the exact same
thing so that's two
check marks in that box all right oh did
she say kim awesome she said kim also
she said she's a little wow
i haven't even talked about that yeah no
she said drew is willing to get a little
more in the mix than kim was
yeah it's the same thirsty than kim kim
wasn't thirsty
you know drew is just parched honey she
is doing everything she can
oh you've dropped so many gifts in this
interview i know we got to wrap it up
shortly if you had to
um sum up this season with one word
what's your word to describe season
thirteen
oh um
i would say juicy
and i mean that as an entendre i was
going to say in
every sense of the word in every sense
of the word honey
juicy as in wope
i don't click down clean back and show
you got this ring okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
profane words just a suggestion
we'll have to catch up when the season's
a little more underway so we can unpack
some of this stuff a little further
yes unpack maybe
unpack a stripper yes
a package okay
[Music]
you